hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the opera euro rapid it's uh wesley
saw versus magnus carlsen and it's the
second game of the match in the first
game it was uh
well it wasn't really a snooze fest but
nothing nothing all that impressive was
going on so i decided to skip this one
and go straight into game two
and if you're wondering why i why it's
taking me so long to upload this as you
know usually i kind of upload
right away it's because i'm already
recording this for the third time
uh interestingly it's a funny story
actually the first time i recorded it
something was wrong with the interface
the the board was like too large and i
didn't notice it and then you know
the whole video didn't really make sense
and then i said uh
okay i'm just gonna redo the video no
you know no big deal and then i redid
the video and then the board was
impressive but
in between the two recordings i uh you
know picked up the mic
and i uh put the microphone you know
so so it wasn't in front of me so the
the second video had the proper board
but
the sound was just terrible so i'm now
so i'm now checking if the board is fine
and if the microphone is nicely placed
so
uh now i'm going to do it for the third
time in case you were wondering and now
i'm also kind of an expert on this game
because i've actually went through it so
many times
in case you were wondering uh so let's
check it out wesley has the white pieces
and as the title suggests this is a
pretty crazy one
uh insane preparation insane engine
lines and you know
uh you know it just is just ruthless so
let's dive straight into it
wesley with the white pieces opens with
e4
uh we have e5 by magnus knight to f3 and
now
knight to c6 we have bishop to c4 uh
checking if magnus is maybe interested
in some evan's gambit
action but magnus says nope not for this
game we're just gonna keep it simple
knight to f6 we have the two knights
defense and now knight the g5 the
so-called knight attack
and opening that's been played for uh i
don't know last 150 years maybe even
longer
uh and defending attacking the f7 pawn
now and there's only one good way to
defend it and that's d5
now for those of you saying yes but you
can also play bishop to c5
i'm not going to argue with you that
that that is a perfectly good move for
for a blitz game uh so d5
by magnus now attacking this bishop we
have e captures on the e5
and now now knight to a5 the so-called
polari defense against this
system bishop to b5 check c6 and now
d captures on c6 we have b captures and
bishop back to d3
uh in the olden days bishop to e2 was
the way to go
the point being that now for example h6
knight f3 and e4 give black a lot of
play
but now in the era of engines you don't
have to play bishop to e2 bishop to d3
is also very much playable as you'll see
in the game
but for those of you interested a bit
more in this opening also queen to f3 is
a possibility
and now preventing captures because the
rook would hang here and if you're
you know interested in playing this with
the black pieces you pretty much have to
know uh these
three uh responses from from whites to
play this properly
so bishop back to d3 this is pretty much
what's played today exclusively
and now knight to d5 opening an attack
towards the knight here
so knight back to f3 and now comes the
bishop to d6 just
nicely developing preparing the castle
both players castle we have castles
castles and now
rook to e1 with a double attack on this
e
uh e5 pawn and now f5 by magnus he
sacrifices the e5 pawn
saying that uh i know this is the best
move because you know i also
prepare for my for my games and this is
in fact the the absolute best move here
as you'll see knight captures on e5 and
now queen to f6 with a double attack on
the knight so knight goes back knight to
f3
and now even g5 so really really scary
looking stuff
black is going all out and white still
has to figure out how to
start developing developing his pieces
so here we have c4
challenging the knight here knight to f4
attacking the bishop here
and now bishop back to f1 and now look
at white's pieces this is just um
this is just incredibly impressive so g4
by magnus attacking the knight here
and now wesley doesn't move the knight
but rather he plays d4
and this is still all theory this is a
well-known uh piece sacrifice that
allows the whites to go
for some very fancy moves so here we
have uh g
captures on f3 magnus captures the
knight uh queen captures and now
as the knight is attacked twice by the
bishop and by the queen just knight to
e6
and now queen to c3 uh attacking the
knight there on a5 also possible is c5
for example because after knight
captures on d4 attacking the queen
you have queen c3 with now this under
attack this under attack and it's
it's pretty fine but after knight to e6
we have queen to c3
now attacking the knight here and now
knight back to b7
we have c5 bishop to c7 and now there is
one game in the database where d5 was
played
but here we have b4 by wesley and it is
only now
as of move 20 that we have a completely
new game
so let's see how magnus deals with this
new idea
those pawns are pretty far advanced so
magnus will use his a pawn to undermine
them we have
a5 and as soon as magnus played a5
wesley instantaneously played b5 saying
that
this is well within my preparation i'm
not not uh
not at all worried and interestingly
here you have to capture the pawn it
looks scary because you give
white two connected past pawns but uh
for example after bishop b2 you're going
to play b4 and after queen to c1
the game continues and you will be able
to to control those pawns but
if you don't know what you're doing it's
very scary and wesley
lost absolutely no time to get to this
position wesley still has over 15
minutes on the clock whereas magnus is
already down to nine minutes
so here uh this is best but magnus goes
for queen captures on d4 he
already grabbed some material he grabbed
wesley's knight and now he grabs this d4
pawn
offers a queen trait but now wesley has
an opportunity to
grab a lot of advantage and you know
make make something of this of this line
so feel free to pause the video here and
uh you know find the absolute best move
for wesley while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
not creating queens and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to c4 just putting another
attacker here
on this night the knight of course
cannot move since the king is on g8
and here we would see uh well a rather
simple line
for example captures captures the knight
is still under attack so knight
captures here defends the knight but now
bishop to a3 threatening to remove one
of the defenders of this knight
and now after knight to e4 blocking the
rook's attack towards the knight
white is very happy because you will
also pick up this rook so knight
captures on e4
f captures and bishop captures on f8
king captures and now b
captures on c6 and yes black does have
two pieces for a rook
but white is up two pawns and white
already has a beautiful past c
pawn this pawn this pawn is very
vulnerable here and it's uh
it's a better position for white to play
especially for wesley who knows the
intricacies of the position and also
yeah well he's much better on time but
here is where
things get uh very interesting after
carlson's queen captures on d4 wesley
actually grabbed the queen
and this is probably where he gets his
uh you know lines uh mixed up
and it's something that happens uh you
know incredibly often in top tier chess
but we're going to discuss
this a little bit more after we check
out the game so here
knight captures on d4 and only now
bishop to c for check wesley probably
hoping for king h8 and bishop to b2
completely crushing for white
but magnus says nope bishop to e6 and
here magnus gives back the piece
and now is able to to you know just
continue developing pieces and this is
probably what what
wesley missed i imagine so here
wesley wins back the piece bishop
captures on e6 knight
captures rook captures and now uh what
do you do do you capture here or do you
capture on c5
all you know both both seem to have
their merits but
knight captures and c5 is actually
correct because now
the rook cannot go after the pawn if you
go after the pawn attacking both pieces
bishop e5 and you lose the rook here
so not not possible uh so instead after
knight captures on c5 we have
rook back to e2 and now preparing bishop
to b2
as uh the rook now nicely defends this
so now we have
uh rook to e8 offering a trade of rooks
uh we have knight to c3 defending and
only now c
captures on b5 making it impossible for
white to capture this because
rook captures rook and even capturing
here and then picking up the pawn is
impossible because you have back rank
weaknesses so rook t1 will just be
checkmate
so instead after c captures on b5 we
have bishop to e3 now going after the
knight
and now bishop to e5 going after this
knight and also the knight is pinned as
the rook is still on
on a1 uh we have bishop captures on c5
bishop captures on c3
and now a trade of rooks captures
captures and now rook to b1 going after
the b5 pawn but magnus just advances it
and even though the material is
completely equal in the position and
even though
and even both players have a dark square
bishop uh the two to one advantage is
incredibly important here
as black's plan is very simple you want
to push this pawn all the way to a3 and
then sacrifice this pawn to make room
for this pawn to march forward
as your dark square bishop is already
nicely controlling the queening square
so let's see if magnus can pull this off
king f1 we have rook to
e5 uh we have bishop to e3 and the
bishop is under attack
and now a4 uh going for what we
discussed we have rooked the c1
and now even a3 we have g3 by wesley and
now
you don't you don't have this right away
if you play this then rook captures and
if b2 then you just
uh uh defend this with uh with the rook
so
uh for the moment it's not possible so
magnus goes rook to b5 now it is
possible
uh because at the end of uh this line
there's rook here so
rook captures on b3 uh we'll just win
the game
so here after rook the c2 uh we have b3
now just offering the spawn a captures
and now
rook captures uh so uh
just uh you know getting getting a nice
position here uh later on you you can
even maybe
uh maybe cut the cut the rook off with
bishop to b2 maybe you can start
advancing the pawn there are there are
various ways you could play this so king
g2 not allowing any chicks to come after
rook to b1 and now king f7 magnus not in
a rush he just continues uh
with this game uh bishop to b2 right
away could run into rook the c8
check and then you might be able to
place your rook here on a8 and
it's going to be a bit hard for this
pawn to reach the a2 square so for the
moment
that's not possible so instead king to
f7 magnus starts improving the position
of the king
and bishop to d2 now wesley hopes to
trade off the dark square bishops as
maybe he's going to be able to draw a
little bit easier
with only rooks on the board so bishop
to e5 and now
bishop to f4 by wesley now again
offering a bishop trade even at the cost
of messing up his pawn structure
and here magnus considered this position
for like 30 seconds before he decided
and he decided to capture this you don't
have to do it but magnus said okay let's
trade here i'm very confident that i
will be able to win this
uh we have rook to be uh sorry rook to
b7 now preparing to put the rook behind
the pass pawn that's what you always
have to do in an end game only then
can you advance the the pass pawn so
rook to a2 blocking and attacking and
now rook to a7
we have king to g3 and now magnus has
two ways of playing this position uh he
can either
force the white king to go queen side
and then he's gonna gobble up the king's
side pawns or he's gonna go all the way
to the queen side push this rook back
and queen the a pawn
so here we have rook to a4 putting
pressure on this pawn here and now king
the h4 or inviting black to capture here
but magnus says
nope let's just keep everything you know
in check i'm just not going to give you
any activity whatsoever so king back to
g3
king f6 and now h3 by wesley we have h5
by magnus and here wesley attacks it
king to h4
we have king to g6 and now king to g3
uh we have king to g7 and now comes king
to f3 now if you go after the pawn
magnus wanted to play king h6 again
opposition and then after king g3 just
king g6 and now what do you play here
uh if you go here then only then will
magnus capture with check
move the rook back to a4 and then you
have free entrance with your king
so instead after this g7 king g7 we have
king f3
now wesley will try to shift the king to
the queen side but now
h4 uh just completely locking the
the the white king out of the game we
have king to e2 and now king of six
magnus now also
brings the king into the game king to d1
king to e6 we have king to c1
king d5 now king to b1 now king e4 going
after this h3 pawn
rook to d2 and now king to f3 not even
bothering with grabbing of the pawn
uh we have king to a2 and now king the
g2
and it was in this position animal 55
that wesley so resigned to the game
and game two goes to magnus carlsen
uh and it's it's pretty incredible how
uh how this game was played so here you
basically resign because uh
you black's just going to capture this
pawn and that's it for example if rook
d5 you go after this pawn
or black can even play rook captures
here and after king captures here you're
just going to capture on h3
move the king and queen the pawn so not
much white can do about this of course
wesley
agrees and he resigns here so it's
pretty crazy how uh
wesley had all of this figured out all
of this plan but
so many variations of course uh it's
always possible to mess
something up and if you don't know
exactly what you're doing uh
in you know in such a dangerous engine
lines your chances are you will you know
lose the threat of the game and then
uh you know your opponent will just
crush you i think uh
i don't remember what game it was i
think it was giri versus mamedyarov
uh i think we've analyzed it like two
years ago where
uh they played like this 23 move uh
preparation
and then uh the first time one of them
had to make a move
it was a complete blunder that lost the
game so the first move you actually made
in the position
loses the game completely so uh modern
chess
is uh is interesting in that uh in that
way but it's also ruthless as you know
everything is just you know whatever you
do you can completely mess up and
just get destroyed so here uh wesley
didn't uh make such a big of a mistake
but
it was it was enough to give magnus the
advantage and it was just
there was just no no returning from that
so it all came down to this after this
uh
queen captures on d4 move by magnus
wesley had to find bishop to c4 but
instead he continued because he he
probably like i said probably missed
that magnus will be able to give back
the piece to get back into the game
so uh really crazy stuff uh magnus takes
game two we'll see what happens in game
three and four and the will magnus be
able to take day one magnus won
uh all the first days in every matchup
and then he just
lost thoroughly on the second day and
then he had to go into thai break so
will it be the same case with wesley
uh or you know will wesley be able to
bounce back in the first match or
you know who knows what what might
happen uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank dan roberts uh
samuel moon constantinos mavro matis
minas yoshi and dragon spice
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day